[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandma's house
hello and welcome to the break room
breakers roomies trash bags all you
folks out there we're so happy to have
you here on a monday and thank you for
coming back this is the break room our
daily show that keeps you posted on all
the nerdy news you need to know right
here from our very own break room at new
rockstars hq in an undisclosed location
coming up today we're going to be
talking about secret invasion we've got
indoor updates out the a-hole and much
much much more going on but first we got
to introduce everyone on the show i'm
brandon who cares across from me we got
erica usu
what up guys
we also have jessica clement
bonjour oh so french
bonjour
uh
we
are all right speaking of we right next
to me is tommy b hey keeping it gucci
and moochie and really trying to hold it
together with jessica and a french
maidon
wow i wonder why i'm in this french maid
outfit
oh
the chef outfit no oh okay
le poisson le
uh what is our redemption today you
might be asking well for every hundred
dollars we raise in super chats uh here
during the break room jessica will make
us a sunday it's monday but we're
getting sundays yeah
we have ice cream and we have other
stuff that goes on the ice cream we have
these uh glasses here which will
determine when we raise that hundred
dollars in super chats that you find
folks send in uh uh we'll we'll do a
poll to see who gets a sundae okay and
it'll randomly be constructed there's
some legitimate stuff over here
for this sunday to be awesome and
there's a chance for this tomato to make
you want to puke guys
look here you guys as a world
world-renowned chef that i am
making a sunday is very easy to do is
the first thing you learn in chef
culinary school so i know how to make
these all very good you start with
sundays yeah it's the second one yeah
and then i move on to creme brulee
sunday's the brulee the sundaes the
brules to boil wow
well send in those super chats and we'll
all be saying bon appetit
ice cream that tastes like feet
okay i didn't say that we're also on
tick tock can you believe it they let us
on tick tock the most restrictive
platform on the galaxy
the break room is on tick tock you can
follow us at the
underscore break room for even more
awesome content if you can't get enough
of us live get enough of us in 30 second
increments yeah i think it's time to
dance you know i think we need to turn
our tick tock into a dancing platform so
i'm gonna be learning some choreographed
dances this week oh okay all right
tommy's going to be doing dancing on
take time i'll i'll attempt to dance but
i i have no rhythm whatsoever oh brandon
i can tell by your eyes you're a dancer
i can see you oh no
i got a lot of heart i got a lot of we
have faith in you uh oh thank you thank
you eric and thank you to everyone who
turned in uh last friday for tomoko what
a lot of fun that was uh we're still
coming down from that all right surprise
atomic thank you and and and for those
of you that emailed in yeah we got a lot
of submissions we're working on sorting
that all out right now we got prints we
got
headshots the ones that requested
headshots what's wrong with you but uh
i'll be honest i'm gonna look for more
yeah how many i can send we have like
over 300 submissions i think just
insanity we are all i mean me i i am
especially touched that uh of my friends
were willing to indulge me on that
insane show but uh and equally as uh
honored that you all tuned in to watch
so thank you genuinely
and we also we do have a winner for this
limited edition science morbius portrait
yeah uh we're working on all the details
on that there is some proprietary
information on them yeah there is we'll
be giving that away as well just our
security code to get into our
our uh
our offices in tarzana yes
definitely in tarzana california hey
it's time for the headlines
hello
[Music]
oh
speaking of
rick and morty co-creator justin roiland
says quote season five was a weird one
but season six will be effing amazing uh
he says it's a bit more canonical and it
really rewards fans of the show that
have been watching up to this point
especially those fans that watch were
explained right here on new rounds
hosted by eric voss and i hope still me
hey if you passed the audition you might
get to keep your job buddy right oh and
by the way i i should mention eric voss
uh had every intention of sending in a
video uh
but it was my fault i did not uh send
him what he was supposed to say and he
had a planned day off and you know i
think the most upset person about that
was my mom who needed to be assured by
me that you guys would still tune in
today so mom they're all still here and
eric will participate in the next comic
con hopefully in person hopefully in
person hopefully first cross we gotta
let him out of the blue dungeon every
once in a while yeah
well not that often he's dangerous when
he gets out of there next headline chung
chi actor simulu teases he'll be busy
the next few years after the san diego
comic-con marvel panel he wasn't at the
marvel san diego comic con panel which
we were kind of joking about here but he
was watching it via twitter yes just
like all of us uh i think we have a
little clip of what he had to say
i was kind of um i was watching the
presentation from from basically from
twitter and being like oh i'm going to
be busy i'm going to be busy the next
few years oh
i mean that's pretty funny yeah we were
kind of joking like he was right there
just like invite him over
is that leaning towards a thirsty
thespian moment i mean he he's saying
he's not right there yeah
i mean he's not wrong he's drinking a
whole glass he's not thirsty because
they were like here's all the jobs
you're gonna have
right but but they didn't say it so is
he kind of just like well if i say it
out loud oh that's true they have to do
it now yeah yeah yeah they don't have to
but but at the end of shangshi that
didn't just say like shanxi will return
and some other i'm pretty sure i think
it said he'll return oh
they said miss marvel will return to
marvel if they know that they're
shooting at blah blah blah i think he
would be great i think he is born to be
an avenger the way that character was
portrayed in that movie and i think that
uh you know giving him a little time uh
away
and reintroducing him as as possibly i
think he could be a leader of the
avengers i think
i think it'd be fun but my whole thing
about him during the avengers i'm like
okay so where does that make where does
that play uh katie uh
no aquafina oh his friend okay
she's gonna destroy it
music or something um he needs a
personal assistant oh god don't make the
woman the personal assistant
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding he'll cook for her
there yeah yeah yeah great chef thank
you a man that can do both have 10 rings
and cook
i do see your point if they bring him to
an avengers movie do they bring katie
too
that wasn't even my first argument are
you know something else and i honestly
forgot it would you guys start going on
your project
[Applause]
we did it guys we did it again we shut
down another uh opinion from a female
with our masculine energy
it is a good point though because you
know a lot of those movies they would
just write off like pepper or jane yeah
being like oh she can't be here right
now
okay well yeah they all got time for
everyone no they'll have katie and ch
and uh shang shi are going to be two of
the non-zombified
oh she
were they listed as the part of the
surviving crew so uh we saw an anime
when they had the the pictures of the
different characters for what if and the
marvel zombies i think she was one of
them yeah if i remember i thought they i
thought in the list it said katie i
don't know guys
do your own research uncle finna get out
there start saying like oh i'm going to
be so what is this new show
speaking of news next headline miss
marvel producer didn't want brie larson
and miss marvel what clickbait here's
the thing
it was actively my desire for her i'll
do it british i don't know if this
person's branded i don't think she is it
was actively my desire for her not to be
in the show overall because i think that
undermines the analogy at the beginning
when kamala's looking in that mirror
she's wearing an imitation captain
marvel cosplay she wants to be this
person and by the end it's not that she
no longer has admiration for captain
marvel but she's seeing herself
end quote uh
[Applause]
i think that's that makes a lot of sense
i think it's valid yeah to be like yeah
i didn't want this bigger character
overpowering the series on this girl um
i want it more to be about her not about
this person so i understand but yeah it
happened but you know why we're all
sitting here like brie larson has got to
show up on captain barb we gotta see
well and i see that more of i see the
producer's point where it's like yeah we
don't want her imitate wanting to be
another person we want her to be herself
yeah good message for young women and
young men everywhere but really it's
like i want the nod i want the the fist
bump i want the the rub that having
captain marvel on the tv show gives it
it gives it a little pin
it shows that it's part of the big the
big league prestige prestige it's a nice
touch
we all agree
uh next
the watcher will be featured and more
what if season two will be featured more
in what if season two and three uh
season two and three will dig into what
makes the watcher tick according to
producer brad winterbomb uh quote we get
to know his humanity a lot more i think
we have a little clip of him talking
about this if i remember correctly
the fact that we have what if
you know going into a third season means
that we can go a little bit deeper with
these characters especially the watcher
uh it's a multiverse story it's a serial
it's a it's a it's a they're standalone
stories but there is a serialized aspect
to it because you have this narrator who
he loves the subjects of these stories
he's the ultimate fanboy you know he's
watching like we all watch and he loves
these characters like we like we do
so so
we we can dig in a little deeper into
what makes him tick and and
and in that in the second season and
then into the third season we kind of
get to know his humanity a lot more
excellent individually yes i think we
got a lot of watcher more than watcher
than i thought yeah we were not supposed
to get so much watching yeah i feel like
uh i'm excited to see him more human the
more humanity because i want to see him
featured playing alongside more people i
wonder because i he was so close to
doctor strange by the end he's like
right you have to watch these people uh
not me anymore so i wonder if he's gonna
finally be like i love humans yeah
humans gave a lot to us why do we hate
them again yeah yeah yeah
because it gets more active less do we
think uh by the end of all this jeffrey
wright
phases into the live action oh i hope so
all right
yeah i mean it might be a thanos
situation oh no i don't think i'm not
making fun of anything he could like
project himself into whatever form he
wants right yeah i
[Laughter]
shanghai again uh and 48 of you said
what if season two a close second uh
she-hulk that would be a great little
cameo yeah
we'll see what to see we'll have to see
uh next headline james gunn says
guardians of the galaxy three might be
his favorite movie whoa of the guardians
i was gonna say
i don't know i think he's gonna watch
him say yes
his favorite movie is edge of tomorrow
lived i repeat
no that's my favorite
i would have guessed kindergarten cop
funny funny favorite movie uh not
kindergarten god
give give james gunn a funny favorite
movie all right here's what here was his
quote he said quote it might be my
favorite movie but it probably wasn't my
favorite shooting experience other than
the love i have for the whole team
i don't know why it wasn't his favorite
shooting experience
gesundheit i'm sorry
i know you did a great job uh
i i bet like a lot of that is like
covered protocol yeah
movie like way less i mean i think that
intimacy like not not you know intimacy
but the intel the level of how you bond
on a set definitely has been different
yeah eric is an actor as well you know
it's like you you you all of you are
also actors but you know i'm just gonna
pump up and things yeah eric pops up and
thinks we're right i'll win
monologue
right now to be
thirsty
well we're all actors but i'm saying you
know uh
it's definitely a different thing you're
not you're not as close you're not as
there's not much communication
communication in between when the
cameras are actually rolling or right
before it's a lot of like everyone go
away and we'll call you exactly when we
need you so i can i bet someone like
james gunner seems to really love like
he says in this quote the collaborative
process of it it probably did feel
isolated it probably did feel very um
lonely lonely especially when you're at
the top and they're like we gotta we
gotta make sure
james gunn doesn't get coveted or this
entire shoot goes down real tight he
he's also not gonna say like oh no
guardians of the galaxy two was my
favorite right after he just shot a new
like your next one's always your your
most favorite one uh he knows how to do
it
um james gunn also said he needed to
finish uh dane he needed to finish the
guardians of the galaxy trilogy for
rocket our little baby boy rocket he
felt close to rocket and we never really
get too much into his background so
that's what it's all about i mean if
you've seen the
uh the the kind of breakdowns of what
the gardens of the galaxy footage they
showed at san diego comic-con said then
you know we're going to learn a lot
about rockets uh here's a little baby
maybe you see a little baby rocket i
don't know it's adorable uh when he was
asked about the holidays how the holiday
special fits into the phase four lineup
gunn called it quote the epilogue of
phase four with a santa emoji i'm
getting so
mad at him
yeah i don't know what this special is
gonna be uh he did cause somebody asked
like if black panther what kind of
forever is the end of phase four and
ant-man and the wasp or
ant-man in the watch quantum medium is
the beginning of phase five and
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
comes out in between those where does it
fit and he said it was i just wanna i
just wanna speak up for everyone voting
for me on the ice cream sunday my
doctors have demanded that i lose weight
so every vote that you get could be
killing me
look at these two in shape m
yeah okay
oh shape i'm using i don't mean to body
shame anybody but let's be honest the
person who needs a sunday the least here
is me you only have to have two bites
and you can spread it out get this man
we are pulling for a sunday thank you to
all our super chatters we've had some
great ones coming in uh dane irving
thank you for your super chat really
please over there uh i want to say to
joe to suave i don't know what buffalo
stadium is but uh
highmark field
is josh allentown okay so i read your i
read your little quote about tom brady
who by the way is looking pretty gaunt
these days i wonder if he's okay you
should get that checked out
wait for something to be wrong with him
uh
but go bills forever and thank you for
your super chat uh charlie 836 saying
jess's outfit is literally everything
today hard-eyed as emojis
the original leho saying wait they
showed a teaser for secret invasion they
did it comic-con and jessica's gonna
break it down here in a second
uh and uh joe to suave sneaking in a
little plug here for any of my roomies
who need a good sci-fi binge netflix
lost in space it's permanently
underrated criminally underrated super
fun watch
uh and then i'm not gonna let me address
the end of this not being lost in space
fan but a lot of people are i'm just not
a hunky robot
he's got a great bod
the robot has a rocking bod robot's got
a rocket vibe i mean listen i'm not
saying anything i'm not sexualizing the
robot but he
objectively it's
got it it's got to rock what about the
robot's mind what about the robot's mind
do we want to care about that do we want
to do this
what's on the outside that counts
like brandon said earlier we have a
container here for sauces toppings and
finishing touches right again yeah you
get the pig oh yeah you gotta pick your
poison again as the renowned chef i am i
will always make this taste good yeah
french strange my assistant john john
young
is going to grab the ice cream from the
freezer great go ahead and choose your
sauce as we wait and brandon will you
grab me the sauces oh yeah the ham's too
fat to get in the cup i would love to
this is why i shouldn't have one
oh it'll be great mustard
great start the first straight we're off
to a good start great start and then the
topping okay
can we throw away just one topping
just one topping yeah just make sure you
shake it so you don't have almost
[ __ ]
is going to be like rusty nails or
something if you're lucky pudding
perfect the pudding is flavored though
what does that match up it is fish
flavored pudding
oh no i think this is will you sing me a
nice french a nice french song as i do
uh
try the gray stuff it's delicious don't
believe me ask the dishes they can sing
they can dance after all mrs fratz and
the dinners here are never second best
come on and fold your menu and we think
that then you'll be our guest be our
guest be our guest
life was so daring
for a servant who's not serving that
mine's problematic
okay does he get no one's over
i want to honor this process
by eating a sardine and mustard oh okay
oh look at you there's such a go-getter
this is it oh that's look at this whole
dinner
for the record there are tons of great
toppings over here you literally pick
the two bad ones you know what
it's as bad as you think
i'm scared yeah
let's get can we no you have to start
right now you can throw it away
yeah give them to me
oh
i'll chuck them throw them in the
kitchen trash please
i understand oh i'm still smelling it
the dog came running the dog
he's like oh open fish i got your water
fish market no go ahead and get your
water go ahead we got a couple of quick
headlines to finish it up here thank you
for that
delicious meal
uh we also got some new she-hulk footage
today uh we're not gonna show it here
just in case you're trying to
stop watching the footage you know we're
in the home stretch now we're like two
weeks away from the premiere they're
gonna be churning out stuff all the time
so we're not gonna show that footage uh
but it's an extended scene of jennifer
and bruce uh in that tropical location
training learning a little bit more
about how much they can drink oh yeah
it's when they're doing the uh
i can do yoga
nice call it out i'll just call it that
we'll save it for you i'm just saying uh
we also asked you some of you folks in
the chat do you think we'll ever see a
live version of this watcher who want to
89 of you said yes i mean they kind of
they said that like right away like oh
they can come in the live action
i think they'll do it eventually uh and
do you think guardians of the galaxy
three will be the best in the series 58
said yes i mean you got to hope for it
to be the best
do you need something to wash out that
flavor yeah
that's the worst thing do you like those
yeah i do you genuinely like circus
peanuts
tommy's the one guy at the grocery store
the honey's pretty good to wipe things
out too this is good i'm back
uh champion tommy you're a champion
uh but those are our headlines today uh
and as one of our super chatters pointed
out there was some
secret secret invasion footage yes uh
that kind of came out of comic con and
we wanted to talk a little bit about
that yes so secret invasions uh just got
also i don't know if this is recent
recent but their synopsis on disney plus
uh
oh i'm so sorry so sorry we wanted to
have the paper towels on the table for
the whole conversation paper towels i
like to eat them
with towels uh the secret invasion
synopsis on disney plus teases a
crossover event series that's what it
says a crossover event series so it's
probably going to be pretty big as big
as a secret war probably not
probably not the uh sardine is on my
nail and i can smell it
why is shane chee not going to be in
secret invasion if it's a crossover
maybe that's where he shows up maybe
so before we even get into that i'm
going to break down really quick what
the trailer was for uh san diego
comic-con i think we already have the
spoiler borders up so if you don't want
to listen to this or just leave me now
um so fury uh returns to earth via
spaceship maria hill meets him at the
bar she says for years you've been
avoiding earth but i've called for your
help plenty of other times and you've
been pretty content to let those calls
go straight to voicemail
and fury says you're right but this is
different
a man who we assume is fury sits across
from rhodey
uh rhodey or the man how much do you
know about uh security detail
rhodey says what do you mean how much do
i know about them we then hear a voice
over from another man that sounds like
talos fury we've got to be very careful
now we see quick shots of a car chase
talos car following closely behind
emilia clarke's character who rides a
motorcycle olivia coleman to fury uh
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us trailer footage suggests
that coleman's character could be fury's
boss amelia clark says this is just the
beginning fury this is my war alone i am
the last person standing between them
and what they really want they cut to
black and then a man says and what is
that
and what is that that's just and what is
that
and who are they and who are they
we have a couple questions through this
already is okay so hill and fury seemed
to dust in the post credit of infinity
war right this series takes place only a
year or two after endgame do we think it
was actually talos or and sarin who were
dusted in that scene how long has fury
been in
i space think it was
justin yeah he had the pager and i don't
think he would give talis the pager it's
it's too risky it's too risky it's too
risky he wouldn't have just taken it
down just take it
don't take it after no that's not me i
think it's risky but i do think that
maybe
talos slipped in this fury during the
blip
and kind of covered for a missing fury
maybe they'd worked something i i i
don't know how fury could know this was
coming if yuri knew that thanos was out
there and was planning this and was like
had a backup plan like hey if i get
dusted yeah you fill in for me while i'm
gone okay do you know how long he's been
in space for as soon as he came back
i mean it would make i i would buy that
and that like he comes back from being
dusted and he's like
brain is like i know i've only been gone
for five seconds but i've thought a lot
about this and now we need to get moving
on a lot of things i think that also
like sword as soon as shield fell like
sword was started like immediately
uh and so that it had been gone for a
little while secretly
uh and then he just kind of went from
there okay sweet later in the week sweet
sorry i i was thinking about this a
little bit as soon as i read it uh so
when we have talos being like fury we've
got to be very careful now whatever's
working with fury do we think that there
is a second scroll fraction on our
faction on earth that we just haven't
met yet
yeah right there has to be more than one
yeah yeah because there's also the good
and bad yeah yeah we've we've seen good
scrolls and that was like the big twist
in captain marvel right because
throughout comics history scrolls are
the the worst of the they're always the
bad guys
uh and then and they got their name even
their name is evil and they got evil
pointy eggs they look like piccolo from
dragon ball z they can't drop teeth
shape-shifting
shape-shifting bad there's nothing
no they're not all bad but in the comics
they're all bad for the most part
there's a couple nice ones there's a
couple living as cows it happens uh
uh it's a good life for is it it's a
good life live is that true yeah there's
a in in the original like fantastic four
in the 60s some skrull coming long story
short reed richards like forces them to
be live as cows
oh my god then they accidentally get
turned into burgers at one point some
people eat those burgers and they get
crazy
there's some crazy stuff that happens
with the skrull cows wow look up the
skrull cows if you're in for a good read
yeah maybe you're in for a good read
this is also where we're getting amelia
clark in the trailer we give emilia
clark on a motorcycle she's clearly uh a
badass
literally a badass um who what is she
playing is she a scroll a scroll
sympathizer uh
this is what i assume every new person
is a scroll right yeah that's the this
is my one quarrel with uh secret
invasion get your quarrels out no it's
just my one word
thank you i say it a lot it's not even
like a beef to be fair because i'm like
genuinely i think it's going to be great
but i hate that i can never figure out
who's who and i don't like that that's
like the justification that you can give
out is like oh they changed and i'm like
wait no no you can't let them just
change last minute you hated battlestar
galactica you're like i don't know who's
a toaster i trust i said this isn't fair
there's a sideline i don't know i don't
know who's the stylist
he's number four
they were all silenced so really quick
in the trailer we see quick shots of the
car chase talia's car following closely
behind amelia clark's character who
rides a motorcycle
so it's like she clearly and then it
says trailer footage suggests coleman's
character could be fury's boss we get
amelia clark saying this is just the
beginning
well she's a bad squirrel
i mean there better be some bad
squirrels i wanna see some super scrolls
up in here i'm not trying to be that
person
i actually know that now i thought about
there's a lot of good people that ride
motorcycles i was about to say what what
character in the mar in the marvel
cinematic universe rides a motorcycle
and is a ghostwriter captain america
america
did you hear the second thing i said
where i was like wait no there's a lot i
got it wrong there's a lot of good nice
and you guys went to those ones i went
to mrs incredible
from the incredible
disney movie
i was like oh she's a good person she
rides a motorcycle eric gets a sunday
dobson is
dutifully letting us yeah yeah i was
gonna do it afterwards we did pass our
super chat threshold again eric's gonna
draw for us well there's nothing bad
left so congratulations on your
delicious sundance
there's diced tomatoes in there i gotta
say my stomach is not right
i i sat through that last segment
looking for god in the rafters do you
want some milk to wash that all down no
i just want to forget that it happened
but i can't stop thinking about that
sardine
that's right
oh you got that vinaigrette zesty
italian vinegar i need another ice cream
i will definitely eat this thank you
chef yes chef thank you chef chef if you
watch the bear you know how to respond
behind her chef corner
i got a cup fire on thirty-one cousin
cousin circus peanuts circus peanut
i've never had a sugar spinach in my
whole entire we're gonna enjoy one now
they're a fat free candy i'll tell you
what candy i'll tell you what they don't
taste good but they got the mustard and
sardine out of my mouth you love to hear
you love to hear it vodka-infused
whipped cream oh
bring it drinking bacon
[Laughter]
uh we did get a super chat from theodore
harrison and this is in line with our
our secret invasion can you sing it in a
french accent while i do this uh oh
theodore harris the apology store of our
french friends out there
in captain marvel there's a sea where
fury tells carol that he can't eat
anything that just cut diagonally now
i'm getting into
image
schwarzenegger
ultron and kitchen scene fiore
called dallas cuts in a sandwich and it
cuts diagonally look at the sandwich
look at this sandwich it's got diagonal
that's a beautiful sundae it's good
[Music]
uh i don't recall this this sequence do
we need to go back and check and yeah
let's track check theodore does he cut a
sandwich and eat it oh here we go
and he's doing it the right way a bite
of everything
oh no
the zesty italian dressing worries me
i'm here yeah
is it zesty
yeah so you're saying me as a culinary
chef is still exquisite
i wouldn't use that word but okay uh you
don't need to hurt my feelings it's
something
i say he finishes it
i've earned this
we're gonna eat around him what's john
yelling about
oh he cuts a sandwich at hot guys that's
pretty good
oh we'll have to go back and check that
one theater we're going to look into
that thank you to all of our super
chatters that got us that eric delicious
also by the way dachshund uh they say
i'm reaching out to you directly in the
great state of texas why is jessica not
in the poll just because she's the chef
doesn't mean she can't eat her own
sundaes yeah why has she been excluded
from this yeah i think she should have
to eat her own
monsieur yeah what's happening here why
was she never an option from the
beginning i should have never had to eat
that honey i say you had tommy and
jessica back to the polls no no no you
did not add me back you can put me on
the plane i can't guys i'm not i'm
seeing a nutritionist now okay i can't
this was already against my diet well
get what if we get you like a wine
bucket and you can spit it out perfect
okay and i'll eat everything perfect
that's what my nutritionist says to spit
everything out speaking of spitting out
i'm gonna spit out this ad real quick oh
baby we want to thank my personal
friends and i will say i hate to say
this saviors and manscaped for
sponsoring the break room this week hey
you
yeah you
got bush
you definitely do if you haven't tried
the best products from our sponsor today
manscaped taking control of your bush is
important god i feel like a 70s porn
producer these products are so good
you're going to be showing pride in your
new bush free yard trim the hedges baby
it's a fact that you will have the best
kept nut sack on the cul-de-sac save big
and be the most hygienic version of
yourself by using our discount code
break room for 20 off
free shipping at manscape whether you're
looking to go bald like an eagle or you
know just neatly trimmed like a bull
mastiff manscape just dedicated to
helping you level up for your full
grooming game full body grooming game
the grooming package i personally
recommend is the performance package 4.0
inside the package is the lawnmower 4.0
this electric trimmer is a bush's worst
nightmare this trimmer is designed to
reduce grooming accidents and shave hair
on loose skin thanks to a ceramic blade
and advanced skin safe technology no
need for night vision goggles this
trimmer has an led light to allow you to
mow the lawn in the dark however if
you're looking for some fun shut all the
lights off and just go to town see what
happens
they've got a bunch of other products on
their website to help you maximize your
confidence and grooming game get 20 off
plus free shipping with our code break
room at manscape.com
that is 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use our code breakroom and
it's time for you to level up from the
amazon to the amadong you know what i'm
saying oh my god these ultimate
bushwhacking tools from manscape thank
you
god knows i love you yes thank you
manscaped i don't know if i got that
last analogy but i i like amazon to
amadon yeah yeah i don't see there's a
amazon in the in south america right yes
and then you would have an ammo
you know what it doesn't
in post it doesn't make a tennessee okay
now it sounds great before we get to
mandatory fun which of course we're
going to get to
landscape is going to come back in a big
way this week because oh you reach a
certain number of dollars in super chats
i'm going to allow the chat to pick
a pattern that i will shave into my
chest
yes that sounds
i will say this
if we get
i got to set it high if we get to twelve
hundred dollars this week
i will shave whatever it will give four
choices to the chat and i want you to
know i'm on the apps i'm dating i guess
okay so this could be devastating for me
so pick something classy like the
necktie or you know an arrow that says
fun town pointing downwards or something
like that it's twelve hundred dollars
i'm just saying if we get there by
friday i'll take a manscaper 4.0
lawnmower to my chest
on a uh on a grooming you're not gonna
make jessica do it on you i'm not i'll
do that i'll be here friday so i could
do it for you okay well merrick's mom
no one's gonna have to touch my chest if
they don't want to but i have a feeling
a few people will volunteer oh my gosh
hollywood's erica wu possibly shaving
tommy's shirt oh yeah i won't be here
friday night watch no i'm not here
friday why but you guys will get a
little a little video footage of where
i'm gonna be oh
oh oh look at that can't wait well
that's awful but this is mandatory fun
all right a a ron taylor johnson
recently spoke with comicbook.com
and clarified his earlier comments that
craven the hunter was going to be an
animal lover which shook the internet
he said i think you know what i meant
what really stated
what i meant what i copied this directly
so this was comicbook.com written this
way
i think you know what i meant what what
i really stated was that he was a
protector of the natural world and i
said he's a conservationist
which is probably more accurate and then
i should have stopped there
full stop that's so funny he was like
you know what
i made a few mistakes and then i should
mention he says then i should have
stopped their full stop and continues
the quote for three more sentences that
i have mercifully
left out for everyone no offense to
aaron glow up from kick ass to craving
the hunter has to be the greatest i mean
quits over in there yeah
yeah well yeah wait a second kick ass to
quicksilver to craven that's crazy i
didn't i forgot there's a guy
in there somewhere too yeah yeah yeah he
was in the front and john lennon and he
played john lennon oh he did he did
nowhere boy he eats a girl's butt out ah
all right he didn't win
tommy
[Laughter]
oh remember the only thing i watch
but it's burnt into my dvd players
and elizabeth olson like kissing
godzilla that's riley a little if you
want to if you ever wanted to see
quicksilver in the sky
the north men for uh with uh
i just don't i don't like siblings i
don't like siblings kissing another real
sibling
has anyone has anyone ever super cut
them kissing from godzilla into some
avengers too
do it internet then and then put the
pornhub boom
at the end
yeah come on it'll be fun someone do it
a little homework for y'all it's not too
much it's not enough this is mandatory
fun hit my graphic again oh my gosh i
thought we got away with it
i almost didn't say it i almost didn't
say it again all right he then went on
to say
john
john shut your mouth he then went on to
say his craven
will be the hunter we all want to see
yeah yeah okay then you know what
don't threaten me with a good time
so a few tweaks to the character seem to
be coming and uh we thought that it
would be fun to make a few tweaks to
some existing spumsy characters to make
them the blanks that we all want to see
you know the the venoms that we all want
to see what have you so for mandatory
fun today we're going to make some
improvements on some spider-man sony
pictures universe of marvel characters
is that what it stands for
yeah sony pictures universe of marvel
case that sounds right but that one
rolls right off the tongue speaking of
rolling off the tongue you guys got to
see nowhere boy featuring aaron taylor
johnson and john lennon oh right who
wants to go first
ah
i could go first i think sure now this
is we can take him from any anything i'm
talking garfield universe i'm talking
you want to go toby mcguire i'll allow
it you want to go garfield the cat i'll
allow that too you want to go jerry
maguire i'll allow that too i mean i
if i went back to the garfield and this
is the one that makes people so angry
right yeah you know what i'm talking
about my boy rhino right oh yeah they
did us dirty with the rhino they teased
me they made it seem like he was going
to be a top fatty and he's barely in the
movie he's got this robo thing and they
were all like we cast paul giamatti and
we're like how are they gonna make paul
do you might look like the rhino and
they copped out no baby i say you go
back
you get a man
you put them in
barely more than a sweat suit some sort
of weird
costume with a with a horn and
everything and just looks like a man in
a weird rhino costume that's what i want
to see baby yeah i don't want any
technological advancements i just want a
magical suit that turned you into a
rhino
like spandex and all with a zipper in
the back that's what i want big horn
coming out the forehead horn coming out
of here full face explodes exposed no
mask no nothing just a man with you know
uh smooth genitals where where normal
don't do that with your lawnmower 4.0
guys it's a ceramic blade okay you can't
hurt
okay good enough all right
now we're only
68 dollars away from brandon having a
delicious sundae
your name's back again we're jessica my
name's not back here
okay so it's just me and tommy's name
just brandon's name alone jessica has
not been a part of any of the other
polls she's out she's the chef
68 dollars and brandon gets a sundae i'm
going family mode for mine my spumsy i
want the osbournes to be redeemed okay
and i'm not talking ozzy sharon jack and
the other one
uh excuse me again
ozzy sharon kelly
papa don't preach
[Laughter]
[Applause]
j master my boy coming in with 50 nifty
dollars we are so close to brandon
eating the sundae baby i can taste it i
want the osbourne osborne redemption you
got chris cooper you got did i take
yours no no no no keep going i was just
whispering to myself oh
we got chris cooper we got dane duhon
okay norman harry first one norman's
first of all he's got a goblin disease
and that's all we see but he's still
kind of a jerk and he gives harry some
really bad advice no i want him cured oh
this is my tweaks i cure him i cure him
and he's kind of like like he gets his
chris cooper swagger back you know he
gets his a little american beauty
insanity you know he gets his uh what
was uh what do you play rich texan in uh
the muppet movie gets that guy you know
he's evil he's rich he's a billionaire
he makes technology we've seen this
before with william defoe but this time
we're seeing it boom defoe is like you
know he's like uh slick gone creepy
mysterious guy j master making sure we
get that sunday made and i see you
i want chris cooper to be a bully a
bulldog of a norman osborn i'm a bit of
a scientist myself m effort
back to formula that's right not going
back to formula now and then harry
osborne dane dehan
i listen to emo i lit a skateboard uh
my mom doesn't love me i was never
kissed by my mom enough good night on
the head not weird but just on the head
not happening nope this danahon is
captain of the football team and i'm
talking european football that's oh he's
playing soccer yeah so he's got that
soccer body lean mean six miles at a
time the osborne's back and better than
ever in my spumsy glow up
this is i can't follow that this is in
the middle i can't follow that that's
right
um my whole beef is with a character
that hasn't even shown up yet oh
and i think it's a spot i want to
despise the villain that's going to be
villain that's going to be in into the
uh
across the spider verse thank you oh
thank you i got i'm getting nervous from
this poll that's why i'm stuttering up
my words
across the spider verse uh if you don't
know if you haven't looked him up he's
really cool but the character from the
comics looks like a dalmatian man and
it's horrifying his eyes are big and his
spots are just weird and not in place
well they're portals right yeah they are
portals there are portals uh and so i
want which the image from it looks like
it's gonna give me this i want him to be
the scariest man in the world i want him
to have no face and if it is a face make
it a black hole that way if you try
punching him in the face it just goes
through his face and you go into another
portal i want it to be deep and eerie i
want you to hear nothing like i wanted
to hear like deep space like in his
freaking face but i also want his dots
to be able to move on their own so that
way it can also alter anybody's
migrating migrating yeah to different
spots on his body i also want to be the
toughest mother you've ever seen oh like
the oscars that i've just pitched
i wanna i want a hot villain and i want
a strong villain i don't want this
scientist that wandered into this poor
this this
this metal cylinder he made and be like
oh the switch and then oh i want yeah i
want him to still be like a hunked up
beefed up man that can just like
straight up be like even if i didn't
have portals on my bodies i could still
fight the hell out of you so i want him
to be the coolest villain because he in
the 80s looks like the saddest funniest
villain but also he has just a great
properties make them make him really
cool sometimes i wish my face was a
black hole
so no one could see me cry
your mouth could be
no that's acting baby
and scene exactly everyone put your
masks on let's go over that
protocol yeah
ah the spoke
character that i would want to redesign
is one eric banas hulk from way back in
the day
chalky green hulk who i would redesign
him entirely top to bottom
and instead of fighting those hulked out
dogs his little villains from that movie
that's the dogs uh maybe a thousand
people saw back in the day
i would have them be his best friends
they would be his thor's goats
and they would be his little allies you
know they would be his thor's goats his
his joker's hyenas his uh his uh hades a
cerberus like those would be his
companions his right hand puppies dogs
are best friends man's best friend
hulked out pit bulls yeah
or should be eric bana's best friends
also better haircut i didn't like his
haircut
in that movie
it was weird you know the hair
technology just wasn't there yet it
wasn't there until that wasn't there two
three not sure so yeah sure i was barely
alive but i'm just gonna come back to
the mcu baby
you know what that means we got eight
minutes to get brandon to sunday guys
all we need is 91 more dollars hey hey a
chef
a chef there's always has to eat their
own creation oh okay before they deserve
it to anyone no i don't like when chefs
do that okay i'm a chef that likes to
just eat and be like i'm remembering
same which artist who makes my subway
sandwich i always think he likes it
yeah my sauce ah
tommy's gonna be so battery
my sauce is honey
your options are pretty good
oh my toppings are graham crackers come
on oh my god this is
that's it we're reading super
corey kandra says eat it
also from last week was wondering do you
think bill murray could be old scott
lang oh that's a good one i like that oh
scotland is what you're singing at new
year's right yes
[Music]
my ex-wife oh
scotland perfect it's beautiful i love
it beautiful yes thank you to all our
super chatters look at mine
robbie rob wow that looks like spidey
one hundred percent okay fifty dollars
so we can make brandon eat something
gross please
i don't care what the rest of the show
does not much gross stuff left i just
want to apologize to the audience we're
not going to get to andor today eric
will have a breakdown of the trailer
tomorrow
if you uh want us to talk about andor uh
tweet at tommy and we'll do it tomorrow
yeah yeah uh there is a new a new
android trailer that came out today chef
finally nailing it finally
wow i'm so glad you finally found your
voice as a chef just in time
uh there was a new android trailer today
uh if you haven't checked it out yet
please check it out it looks like a lot
of fun yeah uh i think there are you
know it was it was exciting a lot of fun
stuff in it like i said maybe we'll talk
about it a little more tomorrow but
there will be a breakdown up from eric
on the channel tomorrow
uh but it looks like they're getting
there the big news out of it though they
pushed it three weeks three weeks it's
not coming out until september 21st well
was it originally supposed to come out
the same day as she hoped it was
supposed to come out
now we're getting a third episode so
much like obi-wan they make us wait a
little longer although everyone was only
two days yeah but we get an extra
episode yeah they dropped three at once
it's 12 episodes total i don't want to i
don't want to be out of school here but
maybe we all do a little sleep over here
and watch the three episodes of andor on
a live stream we might have to because i
don't have time to go home eric's going
to make me do wikileaks the next day i
might as well watch with my besties
i would love that we have five more
minutes to make sure we can get brandon
one of these sundays
uh j master's sending in lots of super
chats thank you so much thank you jay uh
uh charlie836 signing into super chat
craven versus predators i would watch
that man that's all i loved about the
old kids jay master says you're gonna
eat good tonight one more ice cream game
jay masters the mvp of this stream by
far everyone else we love you choose
yourself jaymaster is not trash he's
treasure
okay and that takes a lot dave blonde
sending in a super chat i'm
only here live when i've skipped the gym
and started drinking
early oh no oh no marshmallow sauce
that sounds disgusting
i'm storming off the set of this is a
delicious sundae i'm storming off
what this is the topping
oh god swedish fish
more fish can you hear me hear me the
swedish fish in the marshmallows i love
these let's see what the fish are the
finishing touch the finishing touch
let's see what the finishing touch is
going to be oh oh you got to be joking a
banana no
no absolutely nobody eats the banana but
me
that's two bananas the doctor said you
can't do that anymore
they said banana peels are bad for your
health yeah i don't really like bananas
i don't know oh no you don't like
bananas can you hear me
fish with mustard on it i like sardines
sardines are good i like soybeans too
i'm sitting here in protest for the rest
of the episode
uh did you know that bananas have
radiation in them no they don't yeah
they do you don't have a tiny bit of
radiation so don't eat a ton of bananas
because they'll slowly i know they're
good for cramps so don't open them from
the top like this go like this and you
pinch this little bottom part
no one opens bananas that way yeah they
do people do it all the time the
internet told me so that's a strange
winner also told me that bananas prove
that god exists
but yes thank you to all of our our uh
breakers and our roomies today for
sending in all your super chats uh be
sure to tune in tomorrow we'll have lots
more nerd news to cover
uh won't be upset with us tommy mike's
upset come tomorrow i i don't know if
you can see him back there he's scowling
pretty heavily right now you know he you
once sardine and suddenly your life's
ruined
and we're still doing our clips of the
week on our discord so be sure to clip
out your favorite uh parts of the
episode and share them on our discord
we'll share them at the end of the week
it's been a lot of fun we're also doing
voicemails on our discord join our
discord if you're 18 and over uh and you
can send in a little voicemail ask us
anything ask us questions about movies
about tv shows or ask us about our
personal lives
sorry i got soaps oh this is so gross
it's so disgusting mine's horrible
that's why i almost finished it yeah
yeah i'm sorry disgusting uh but thank
you for tuning in and we hope you all
have a great rest of your monday and
we'll see you here tomorrow live on the
break room goodbye